I'm Kelly.
I'm originally from New Jersey, and
I moved out to San Francisco
about a year and a half ago.
I think it took me so
long to get into computer science
because no one told me about it.
And I wish that I had been introduced
to it earlier, but then again,
it's not too late.
So that's why I'm excited about these
programs, such Udacity's program.
And I think that if I had been
introduced to computer science during my
undergraduate degree,
I definitely would have pursued it.
One of the things I'm really excited
about for this nanodegree program,
is I feel like it gave me a really good
foundational base in web development,
and I'm excited to put that
to use in the work place.
So what I love about programming is just
the whole problem solving process, and
I actually love how at times it
can be extremely frustrating, and
you can sit in front of your computer
for hours confused and just frustrated.
But then that moment when it actually
works is just the best feeling.
[MUSIC]